the heaviest rainfall in more than a
decade has caused deaths and flooding in
Jakarta and surrounding areas in West
Java the rain began on Tuesday night and
triggered landslides on the city's
outskirts Indonesia's meteorology
department has called the rain very
extreme nearly twenty thousand people
were stranded as Jakarta's domestic
airport was shut down after its runway
became submerged people have drowned and
others have died from hypothermia or
been electrocuted as power supplies were
damaged by the flooding thousands were
forced to evacuate their homes crews are
pumping out flooded areas and rescuing
those who are stranded the Indonesian
disaster agency says the rains and
rising rivers have submerged at least 90
neighbourhoods flooding is common in
Jakarta this is monsoon season and
forecasters say more downpours are on
their way Skott Heidler al Jazeera and
so I mean the pictures were dramatic in
that report by Scott Heidler I mean this
is some of the worst flooding that the
capital Jakarta seen in about five or
six years you've got family there what
are they telling you I mean how bad are
the floods and where the worst-hit areas
briefly yes I do have a family in
Jakarta they live in East Jakarta one of
the five districts in the Capital Region
but my immediate family members my
parents and siblings their spare from
the flooding they've been spared in even
the worst flooding that occurred in the
past the previous one in 2013 the ones
who live in the different neighborhoods
unfortunately are not so lucky their
neighborhoods are flooded they're still
sussing the kind of floods that are
engulfing the city right now but some of
the most hit areas I would say in the
northern part of Jakarta so so and to
what's what's causing this current bout
of flooding is it about bad water
management poor drainage low-lying
floodplains or is it more complex than
that it's all of the above it's it's a
complex issue but as you pointed out
those three factors and more have been
contributing to the floods
of all Jakarta sits on a low-lying
Plains and has been expanding since the
city was founded several hundred years
ago and now it's an totally urban jungle
concrete covered the city in many many
places though there's less greeneries
and in green spaces to absorb rainwater
for example and there's a poor drainage
system and coupled with that many
residents of Jakarta have been pumping
water from underground from the aquifer
for their water needs because the water
from the main supply is still inadequate
and this to subsidence of the city in
fact Jakarta has been said by many
experts is one of the fastest thinking a
city in the world because of that the 13
rivers that pass through Jakarta and to
the big ones include Chilean River and
she says that a river cannot properly
drain to the Java Sea let's let's
quickly talk about the government
response I mean what's the government
doing about all of this and can it cope
with this level of natural disaster
because these are enormous floods yeah
what I've learned so far that the
provincial government of Jakarta because
Jakarta it is administratively governed
as a province a special capital district
is building command posts and
instructing hospitals and health clinics
all over the city to help address
regular issues that usually come after
flooding dank fever diarrhea all sorts
all sorts of problems that come from
waterborne diseases that I know what the
government is doing I'm sure it can
handle it because Jakarta has
experienced this in the past and so it
has some measure of experience in
mitigating their problem optimism thank
you much indeed for sharing your
thoughts with us thank you